hmm so that's how I got some foliage
around this jr. coaster magically out of
nowhere pretty much in this episode I'll
just be doing some random gibberish
Venter really trying to figure out flat
rides and decorations scenery stuff like
that you could see the peeps walking
around like chickens without a head
because well that's er that's all my
complaint list the developers might very
well be watching this video but I am
creating quite an extensive complaint
list at the moment which of which well
includes all my complaints about this
game really and one of them but this is
being worked on is the fact that the
guests are currently pretty stupid the
not as stupid as roller coaster taken 1
and 2 guests they actually know how to
use transportation rides and things like
that which is really cool but so far a
part that's wider than one tile still
confuses them terribly so um yeah my
poke isn't really perfect for the peeps
I mean the guests in this game they call
guests officially which I'm happy about
but yeah I was never really too big of a
fan of their peeps speaking of past by
the way this over here is really awesome
it's in vitamin E who doesn't know it's
an employee path and only employees can
use those paths and they'll take them if
it's a shorter route to deliver goods to
shops things like that which is really
cool to see and they're actually using
the employee paths as well so really
love that system already i'll also be
trying to actually add some simple crown
shrubbery pretty much people who have
also watched my roller coaster get three
stuff will know what i'm talking about
with that i'm way too well I wouldn't
say obsessed but I think Roger Aubrey is
very important and so far it's been
pretty much missing from this game that
being said as I am saying this right now
there is actually a new mod pack the
Dino pack which if you haven't picked it
up yet and you do have this game pick it
up on the pike sec nexus is really
awesome but it's actually got some small
shrubs in there which would be perfect
for grant robbery but at the time of
making this video the dino pack was far
from release
so that's that's a bit of a thing which
is why I've been spamming flowers so far
in every corner of the park and will
continue to do so for the next five or
so episodes just to make sure that the
ground actually has its fair share of
foliage as well and that's well
basically the park won't start looking
empty and just one big empty grassland
or a six flags in general because I'm
not a big fan of that and yeah that's
pretty much that so far I do have to say
one of my favorite things of doing so
far in the game is really just getting
small Pike decorations and hedges and
fences and flowers which I've loved in
roller coasters I can run into but so
far the system for that in this game is
really awesome as well and this building
over here will be a very small food
court over here it's a bit closer to
Main Street really but I had this large
open space over here and I really felt
like I had to fill it with something and
yeah food court always goes I suppose
there were quite a number of trials that
I had to try and get this bill neat
actually look like something here's the
first version which I think looks like
well absolute nonsense so that's why
that didn't make it to the final cut
this one was slightly different but
still don't make it the flat roof was
still very awkward and I think in the
end it really took was just a normal
corner roof like that and just some good
old decorations the really amazing thing
so far that even though this game is
quite similar in in while its style in
general but also the objects that you
have to roller coaster tycoon one and
two but what it really sets it apart
from those games is the fact that you
don't have any collision restrictions on
the building elements which might just
be a mod thing but so far it's really
amazing because even though the building
think the building elements are very
simple and very limited you can make so
many different things with it already
just mixing different roofs into each
other to get new color schemes and new
shapes and you can do the same with
walls and floors and it's really amazing
these with even so little pieces you can
make so many different things
that's pretty much all so why this
building sort of worked out in the end
though I do have to say it does look a
bit Western and then especially with
that large balcony around the entire
building which is technically a porch
but it works as well it works as a
balcony putting those pillars underneath
it which actually works surprisingly
well so yeah I'm not sure how well it
all fits into a what's supposedly an
Alpine park by them I might at some
point just drop the idea that this is an
Alpine Pike and just make it the sort of
general sense that this Pike has in
general because it's not really to
become an issue to kind of do like that
and you can see me struggling with the
terraforming over here terribly which I
should probably excuse myself for in
hindsight because at the moment for
building this I was literally screaming
and cursing at this game for how
terrible this terraforming system was I
thought but um yeah even though there's
some minor issues with raising and
lowering land I completely didn't
realize the fact that there is actually
a flattened option which makes
terraforming life in this game much
easier so don't worry about that I did
gets the terraforming uses I did kind of
understand the terraforming system in
the end but in this video I still
terribly suck at it and it looks a lot
worse in this video then it actually
works in the game itself as soon as you
realize that you can actually flatten
blend and by using that make some pretty
good Hills and shapes or even lakes it's
a lot easier and really I barely even
use the lower or raise function in the
end but um yeah that's pretty much that
this is a bit of recoloring of the of
the rides I don't know if anybody else
finds themselves doing this but I always
find myself in roller coaster tycoon one
and two recoloring the rights of the
college that you could see in the little
and no the little preview icons of when
you place the rides and I kind of find
myself even getting those same color
schemes in this exact game so just
getting those old color schemes from
roller coaster taken one and two for
different wines and trying them in this
game and actually it works pretty
no I mean it's it's pretty common for
the what is it called I think it's a
call a chair swing but it's probably
called something else in this game like
flying something but for the the flying
chair swing thing they're always white
and red pretty much and same goes for
carousels but really when it comes to
Ferris wheels i think that one of the
standard Ferris wheels and roller
coaster tycoon one was white sort of
nodes with blue ring around it and that
actually works really well in this game
is too and you have to be quite fair the
color scheme of the junior coaster was
also inspired by gentle Glen so I don't
know if it's Billy too good of a thing
to be copying color schemes for Molly
coaster tycoon one and two but these
same color schemes that worked in those
games are really amazing in this game as
well so that's kind of funny and this
fried in the end almost looks a bit
Asian with its little square things but
that's a bit of a site thing I'm also
placing way too many hedges that was
something that always happen in Mali
coaster tycoon one and two and it's
happening over here as well it's
supposed it's a bit of an issue
sometimes that when you get into these
soon certain ways of thinking and
building things they sort of just become
standards and I see myself trying to
even follow them in this game especially
when it comes to the small scenery not
necessarily when it comes to the
buildings but when it comes to
recoloring things and small scenery I
find myself doing way too many things
that I was doing in bala codes that i
can wanted to add something i want to
fix but yeah the rest of this episode is
pretty much useless banter throwing out
random rides which i probably shouldn't
have done knowing that this was a time
lapse usually what I should have done is
gone into a separate park vinyl just
kind of mess with rides not recording
and not making a mess of the entire
video so I'm sorry that this video is
becoming a bit of a mess at the end I
was trying multiple rise and multiple
little things like I've random I didn't
even know what the entire idea was
behind this but random towers over here
which I think in the end I removed a
couple of episodes ahead so that was
pretty useless and then I was bored
again and built some planters it's
this is terrible but yeah that's had to
pretty much this episode though I do
have to say I did start on the
beginnings of a wooden roller coaster
which I kind of like so far but I'm not
really getting too far with that this
episode is really a bit sometimes you
have to do those little things to finish
up your park which aren't really all too
spectacular and sometimes a bit boring
and take a bit of experimentation and
that's what pretty much I had to try in
this episode try to get a observations
that were over there to see how that
would look I actually don't remember why
I didn't go with it in the end I think I
just didn't want that over there because
yeah I already had so many raised rides
that had their own little pendant
pedestal that they were placed on that I
felt like I couldn't do it for another
ride over there and that's when I pretty
much started doing all kinds of random
things and finally got my act together
and decided to build a wooden roller
coaster because this space over here its
way to launch think ely get some rides
in and traditionally you would have some
of the larger roller coasters and rise
around the side of your park which is
why i'm going to attempt to build a
wooden roller coaster and this is the
infamous wooden roller coaster that took
me way over an hour to build not even
counting this part of me building it
which took a lot of experimentation to
kind of see where i wanted to go it does
look in the video that you can see over
here it does probably look like the coso
editor isn't really too great in this
game but I do have to say especially for
wooden roller coasters I think it's a
lot better than roller coaster tycoon 3
one of the main issues that I always had
in Mali coaster tycoon 3 is that you
can't have smooth hails or smooth curves
it's always very janky it's not even a
word it's so it always it's always very
bumpy and stuff like that just not
smooth I can't find the right words at
the moment but you probably know what I
mean and since you can increase the size
so even the length of a straight section
but also the size of a curved section
you can make much smoother woodys in
this game then in roller coaster tycoon
3 and since Woody's are so much
dependent on their little
time hills and helixes things like that
I think that's a large factor for making
woods in this game and I really love it
about this game so far that being said
this layout was a bit of a fail so I had
to remove that at some point but in the
next episode I'll be finishing off this
wooden roller coaster in like half an
episode which should be fine from that
point onward in any case I'm running out
of time for this episode so thank you
guys for watching and I'll see you guys
next time